a cesariana muitas vezes chamada tese
ajudaria é um procedimento cirúrgico
no qual são feitas incisões no
abdômen e no útero de uma mulher para
dar à luz um bebê algumas cesarianas
são planejadas no entanto a necessidade
do processo geralmente se torna aparente
após o início do trabalho de parto
quando as condições anormais que
causam um parto natural não são
seguras para a mãe o bebê
as indicações comuns para uma
cesariana são distância partindo da
prf esse sentimento fatal
distância o trabalho não progressiva e
prolongado pode ocorrer quando a cabeça
do bebê não se encaixa no canal de
parto
o corpo está em uma posição
desfavorável como quando a questão de
colar ao canal de parto ou nádegas como
é a posição pélvica apresenta
tendência ocorre quando o paciente que
está em uma posição baixa o destruir
parcialmente ou totalmente a mistura do
colo do útero
o sofrimento fetal ocorre quando a
saúde do bebê está em perigo iminente
geralmente devido ao fluxo insuficiente
de sangue através da placenta ou do
cordão umbilical o sofrimento fetal
pode ocorrer quando a percentagem
separada parede uterina antes do parto
o cordão umbilical se comprimem ou
assepsia
outras condições que podem exigir uma
cesariana em conhecimentos multiplus
grandes tumores de útero despeje em
natal outras infecções ou problemas de
saúde como hipertensão o debate se
não controlada o médico pode utilizar
a ultrassonografia em uma leitura fatal
do coração para ajudar a decidir se o
bebê deve nascer por cesariana
quando uma cesariana se torna
necessária será preparada para a
cirurgia se ainda não está no lugar um
tubo intravenoso será iniciado em um
cateter será inserido em sua bexiga
para drenar a urina na sala de cirurgia
do câncer será beneficiada na maioria
dos casos uma resistência peridural é
administrada para anestesiar apático
filhos do corpo no entanto às vezes é
usada ainda esteja em geral o médico
começará a fazer uma incisão no
abdômen será uma incisão vertical um
pouco abaixo do umbigo até a parte
superior do osso púbico ou muitas vezes
uma incisão eles vão tallin cruz
espinho um pouco acima do osso púbico
esta encenação é geralmente chamada
de incisão biquíni em seguida o
médico realizará uma segunda
inserção na parte inferior do útero
após a abertura do lutero o médico
rompia bons a minha ótica e se ainda
estiverem intactas e em seguida o bebê
nasce o tempo entre inspeção inicial a
vida animal pia nascimento é
normalmente de 5 minutos
o médico então tem de cortar o cordão
umbilical
quem move cuidadosamente apresentar piso
tura costura firmemente moiteiro mil
habitantes em que isso normalmente leva
cerca de 45 minutos normalmente o
período de internação após uma
cesariana de três a cinco dias
durante esse tempo você será
incentivada a amamentar tirar um cochilo
quando deve definir que levantar da cama
com freqüência embora a maioria dos
pacientes passa a cuidar de seu bebê
recém nascido após o procedimento
a recuperação total pode levar de seis
para oito semanas a cicatriz ficará
mais claro e conforme for se regenerando